there's more to Keanu Reeves than the
characters he plays and he's got the
fascinating life story to prove it
here's a look at just how the John wick
star went from a high school dropout to
the captivating actor he is today Reeves
is Canadian but he was actually born in
Beirut Lebanon where his mother Patricia
Taylor a British costume designer and
performer met his father Samuel Reeves
but his dad was essentially out of the
picture by the time Reeves was a toddler
as a result he basically went wherever
his mom's career took them they lived in
Sydney in New York and eventually they
settled down in Toronto Reeves
definitely has a multicultural
background in addition to his travels he
was also exposed to Chinese and Hawaiian
culture through his grandmother he has
also said that his mom taught him
british mannerisms and passed down some
of those customs and formal attitudes
his upbringing may have been
unconventional but he definitely became
more cultured because of it Reeves his
mother was quite well-connected in her
line of work as a result little Kiana
met lots of celebrities when he was a
kid his mother worked for David Bowie he
also remembers spending time with Emmy
Lou Harris and Dolly Parton apparently
Alice Cooper even babysat for him I
remember that he that there was fake poo
in the fridge that was apparently par
for the course like an Alice Cooper
blade aired I don't know if he did that
yeah Alice do you remember doing though
I'm sure he remembers that it's easy to
see why Reeves became interested in
acting at a young age as an early
exposure to so many celebrities Shirley
made it seem like breaking into
Hollywood wasn't a far-fetched fantasy
if his mother could work her way up and
connect with some of the biggest rock
stars in the world why couldn't he
achieve his own dreams
Reeves is an exceptionally talented
actor but he was not the world's best
student over the course of five years he
attended several different high schools
when he was a freshman he wanted to go
to a school that was highly ranked for
academics but later he decided to
audition for Toronto's Etobicoke School
of the Arts he was accepted but
unfortunately he ended up getting
expelled he said that he enjoyed his
time there but he's also admitted that
he simply wasn't cut out for such a
structure too academic environment
Reeves isn't the only actor in Hollywood
who didn't finish high school and like
many other creative young people he
thrived in alternative environments he
also had dyslexia which certainly didn't
help matters but he enrolled in a class
called respect for acting as well as
sketch and improv courses with second
city Toronto and he continued attending
these classes at night and honing his
craft Reeves is a man of many talents in
addition to acting in movies and theatre
he's also spent plenty of time on the
ice playing hockey in fact at one point
in his life he hoped to play
professionally while attending De La
Salle College in Toronto
he played goalie and he was quite the
formidable opponent he was so skilled at
net minding that he earned the nickname
the wall when he was younger Reeves
dreamed about representing Canada in the
Olympics one day but when he decided to
dedicate himself to acting he put that
dream on the back burner he continued to
play hockey on a recreational basis but
he chose to put acting first Reeves may
have started out as a young
jack-of-all-trades but he chose to
commit his life to becoming a master of
one and that decision has clearly paid
off one of Reeves his first professional
gigs was working as a correspondent on
the Canadian Broadcasting Corporation
Youth Program going great the show
focused on child prodigies who were able
to accomplish amazing things at a young
age do it they fired me after the first
year one year going great
Reeves also appeared in another local TV
production called hanging in a scripted
series about kids who attend a
Counseling Center in a rough part of
Toronto
he described hanging in as a godsend for
young actors in Toronto at the time who
were just trying to get a foot in the
door and make some connections in the
industry Reeves is not just skilled as
an actor he's also a gifted musician and
he was the bassist in a band called dog
star in the 90s and 2000's the band got
its start when Reeves ran into vocalist
Robert mail house in a grocery store in
1991 the two bonded over their mutual
love of hockey and eventually they
realized that they both liked jamming
out together - two more friends joined
the band and as their fan base grew they
started touring they even played some
pretty big festivals like Glastonbury in
England the band broke up after
releasing their second album because the
members were
busy with other commitments in
particular Rivas career was really
taking off with the popularity of the
Matrix films but this wasn't the end of
Rivas musicianship as he and Mail house
would go on to perform together some
more in a band called Becky maybe he can
whip out that bass in the next John wick
movie shredding on some strings could
totally be a useful tool in an
assassin's arsenal check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]